[موسيقى]
انا من الشرقاوي اهلا بك معنا ادم دور
سامح في في مسلسل الف حمد لله على السلامه
مع الفنانه الكبيره يسرا يعني كان له صدى
عند الناس كتير قوي يعني يمكن زي بتزيف في
لعبه نيوتن
جالك الدور ده ازاي جات لك الفرصه دي ازاي
من طريق
في رمضان
دور سامح هو
ابن استاذ يسرا جاي من بره
والورق حلو فاقرا وشوف ايه رايك نريت
عجبني اول الموضوع شفت ان فكره المسلسل
كانت حلوه قوي وانا هقدر اعمل حاجه
بالورقه فاتبسطت وطبعا شغل مع استاذ يسرا
قلت لازم لازم اعمل كده
مع الفنانه يسرا كلمني كده عن الاجواء
بتاعته واتعلمت منها ايه تعلمت حاجات كتير
اول حاجه يعني بني ادم ازاي يعني
عامل مع المشاكل
وفي التصوير ازاي تتعامل باكتر طريقه
وازاي تبقى هادي يبقى عندك صبر
وتسيب الحاجات تيجي زي ما هي تيجي كده
يعني تفكر في الحاجات اللي انت هتقدر
تغيرها بس ما تفكرش في اي حاجه غير الحاجه
اللي في ايدك
وانا كنت محتاج
اشوف حد بيتعامل بالطريقه دي قدامي في
الفتره دي انا جلال مدبولي المسيطر اكتب
وصياتي من هنا من كندا بان تقول ثروتي الى
زوجتي الدكتوره سميحه جاهين السويسي
مولتي
واي فاي ولا انت
ادم دور سامح ودور برده بيجزيه في لعبه
نيوتن للتاني مصري دور مصري عايش في
امريكا وانت فعلا انت كدام انت مصري كنت
عايش في امريكا هل مش خايف ان ده يحصرك في
المنطقه دي خالص اول حاجه انا حاسس غير
طريقه الكلام سامح
مش شبه بعض خالص
لو بنتكلم تمثيل ولا حضرت للدور ازاي لا
سامح مش شبه بعض خالص غير في طريقه الكلام
وانا برضو في خمس جولات عملت دور حد مصري
مصري فاهمه قصدي ما فيش كلام
ابوه كان عايش بره ولا امه كانت عايشه بره
ولا هو كان جاي من بره لا ده حد ده شاب
مصري
فانا انا انا انا مش خايف ان انا هتحط في
الحته دي
وفي نفس الوقت مش عايز اضيع الحته دي عشان
دي حته مني يعني ده ده انا انا مصري بس
برضه كنت عايش بره فهو ممكن اقعد ابقى ميه
في الميه مصري وممكن ابقى المصري اللي
عايز
اركز في الحتتين عشان انا انا الاثنين
اشتغلت ايه سينما خمس جولات هيبقى اول
فيلم سينما
اه اول او اه اول فيلم في السينما هنا
مصر ولا بره سؤال صعب بس عاجبني قوي
عاجبني قوي بصراحه عشان
انا مش عارف ده احسن رد على السؤال انا
انا بجد مش عارف انا هبقى بين هنا وهناك
طبعا طبعا
على حسب الشغل يعني مثلا السنه اللي فاتت
انا عملت فيلم واحد في امريكا
ده نزل على نتفليكس
بس نادي لسه ما صورتش حاجه جالي فرص اصور
حاجه هناك بس الوقت ما كانش مناسب كنت
بصور لسه هنا في رمضان وانا شفت ان لا
الشغل هنا مع استاذ يسرا هيساعدني اكتر من
البروجكت اللي انا هعمله هناك فانا بحاول
اوزن الحاجات كده شكرا جدا يا ادم
وبالتوفيق ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]